xavier dolan avait présenté à cannes son
tout premier film j'ai tué ma mère
dix ans plus tard il tentera de mettre
la main sur la prestigieuse palme d'or
du festival avec mathias et maxime 5,6
fois que j'y vais pied toujours avec des
films faire un pied dans des catégories
différentes le savez que la troisième
fois en compétition mais toujours les
expériences qui sont assez variés pour
la petite histoire les amours
imaginaires il laurence anyways ont été
présentés dans le volet un certain
regard momy a remporté le prix du jury
est juste la faune du monde le grand
prix
mais cette année les habitués du
festival le vivra autrement cette fois
ci le le trait pour moi c'est de de lomé
avec des amis avec les gens avec qui je
lis qu'il ne pouvoir redécouvrir le
festival arts en fête à travers leur
regard et maxime l'amitié est d'ailleurs
au coeur du nouveau film du réalisateur
de 30 ans dans mathias et maxime un
moment intime entre deux membres d'un
clan va créer des remous
xavier dolan y incarne le rôle titre
pour le directeur photo du film
cannes c'est la consécration que de la
joie c'est vraiment l'endroit au monde
on veut prochaine instruments première
très stressant les films vont être
commentée votre vue et commentée par les
médias partout dans le monde dans tous
les territoires avec pour la vente d'un
film c'est très important
autre réalisatrice et un premier film
monia chokri le premier long métrage de
monia chokri la femme de mon frère sera
aussi projeté à cannes dans le volet un
certain regard une rampe de lancement
pour de nouveaux cinéastes je ne fais
pas touché il ya que je suis la lutte
s'annonce déjà féroce entre les 19 films
annoncés dont ceux de pedro almodovar
ken loach et les frères dardenne
mais il reste encore de la place pour
d'autres dont celui de quinting
tarantino sur 25 ans après le sacre de
paul crutzen cherche encore à se frayer
un chemin jusqu'à cannes
ici julie jasmin moudre aux ados canada
montréal
[Musique]